>> I AM HERE TO SAY THAT YOU
MIGHT BE IN A CULT TOO IF YOU
DON'T KNOW THE SIGNS THAT I DO
BELIEVE DEMOCRATS ESPECIALLY ARE
IN A DEEP CULT, THEY REALLY
DON'T KNOW ABOUT AND AREN'T
REALLY AWARE OF.
>> THAT WAS ACTRESS ROSE MIKE --
RESPONDING TO THE HATE WITH THIS
VIDEO ON TWITTER LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I DID AN INTERVIEW ON
FOX NEWS, CAUSES SUCH A
COGNITIVE DISSONANCE AS SOMEONE
WHO WAS BASICALLY WHEN I SET
FOOT IN AMERICA, A DEMOCRAT,
NEVER THAT FOX WAS THE ENEMY.
ROSE SAYS DEMOCRATS ARE IN
OCCULT, BUT I ALSO SAYS
REPUBLICANS WERE TOO.
>> YES, SHE DID.
SHE DID PROVIDING THAT CONTEXT
AND WE GOT THAT LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE SHE HAD A FEW SALTY
WORDS TO USE THAT WE WEREN'T
GOING TO PUT ON TV.
JOINING ME NOW IS RACHEL CAMPOS
DUFFY WHO PROBABLY IN PRIVATE
LIFE SWEAR SOMETIMES AS WELL.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU, REACHED
OUT TO ME, REACHED OUT TO ROSE
WHO IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM YOU,
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT FROM ME, WHAT
WAS YOUR TAKE ON WHAT HAPPENED
LAST NIGHT?
>> I LOVED HER INTERVIEW AND I
DON'T THINK SHE CAN SAY THESE
THINGS ON ANY OTHER NETWORK AND
WHAT THIS MOMENT BECAUSE FOUR IS
I DON'T AGREE WITH A LOT OF
THINGS THAT SHE STANDS FOR, I
KNOW YOU DON'T EITHER, BUT WHAT
THIS MOMENT IS CALLING FOR IN
AMERICA RIGHT NOW ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE WILLING TO GO BEYOND
IDEOLOGICAL -- THIS POST
IDEOLOGICAL MOMENT WE ARE IN
RIGHT NOW AND TRULY BELIEVE WE
ARE IN THIS 1976 MOMENT SO SHE
IS SPEAKING TRUTH TO POWER WHEN
SHE SAYS SHE CALLS OUT
KAMALA HARRIS FOR PROMOTING
WIDTH OF ALL PEOPLE OF
BILL CLINTON OF ALL THINGS
WOMEN'S AND GIRLS EMPOWERMENT,
SHE WENT AND GAVE HOLLYWOOD, YOU
CAN'T CROSS THOSE KINDS OF
IDEOLOGICAL LINES IN HOLLYWOOD,
VERY STRICT ENFORCEMENT,
STRICTER THAN EVEN ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES SO YOU WHEN I ALSO
DON'T FIT INTO VERY NEAT BOXES
FOR WHAT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
THINK AS WOMEN, ME AS A MINORITY
AND YOU AS A LESBIAN.
AND WE ARE SEEING WHERE TRUTH
TELLERS WHERE YOU ARE I COMING
TOGETHER PUTTING ASIDE OUR
POLICY PREFERENCES AND SAYING
THIS IS A MOMENT TO STAND.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY DON'T WANT.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
HOW MUCH WE HAVE IN COMMON AND
THAT HAPPENS, OF COURSE SOMEONE
LIKE ROSE SPEAKS UP BECAUSE YOU
THINK WAIT A MINUTE, CAN RELATE
TO HER.
THIS IS THE THING THAT IS
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE ARE FACING
AS A COUNTRY AS WELL.
>> YES.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT FREE SPEECH,
IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT YOUR
HEALTH LIBERTY AND THIS PANDEMIC
MOMENT, WORRIED WE ARE TURNING
INTO A SURVEILLANCE CULTURE THAT
IS COMMUNIST CHINESE STYLE, IF
YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT MANY OF OUR HEALTH
BUREAUCRATS ARE COMPROMISED BY
THE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
BIG PHARMA, THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
THINGS FOR US TO AGREE ON
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT ABOUT PARTY,
THIS IS HOW SAD AND HOW BADLY
THE FREEDOM MOMENT WE ARE LIVING
IN THAT WE HAVE TO COME TOGETHER
BECAUSE OF AMERICA, NOT BECAUSE
OF OUR PARTY.
IF YOU LOVE AMERICA, THIS IS
YOUR MOMENT TO TELL THE TRUTH,
TO SPEAK UP, TO HAVE COURAGE AND
NOT BE AFRAID OF BIG TECH.
OF COURSE, THEY ARE DOING ALL
THE THINGS I ALWAYS DO TO THOSE
TRUTH TELLERS.
NOT ONLY SHADOW BANNING US AND
CANCELING US, CALLING US CRAZY,
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS, IF THE NEW
RACIST, BY THE WAY.
>> HERE'S WHAT I RECOMMEND FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW ROSE, SHE
HAS A LOT OF THE VIDEOS UP AND
MORE COMMENTARY ON TWITTER, ALSO
ON INSTAGRAM, GO AND CHECK IT
OUT, YOU'LL FIND YOU WON'T AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING BUT YOU WILL BE
FINE BECAUSE THAT'S WHA